it's great to welcome Brian green to the
program today who is a professor of
physics and mathematics and director of
Columbia University's Center for
Theoretical Physics also known for his
groundbreaking discoveries in super
string theory and author of many books
including I believe most recently it's
until the end of time right that's your
latest yes that's correct
exactly so maybe to get into our
conversation when somebody maybe is
trying to understand not something like
super string theory or or the nuts and
bolts but more generally what types of
questions does your work seek to answer
to have a broader understanding of what
you're doing how would you explain that
to them well certainly in in in my the
newest book that you just made reference
to until the end of time the goal is to
give the curious person a sense of how
they fit within the cosmic hole I mean
the journey that I take in that book is
from the very beginning of time walking
through the sequence of steps that yield
life and conscious beings and on to the
very far future and within that cosmic
unfolding my goal is to give the person
a sense of where they came from the
environment that they're in now where it
came from and where things are going
with ultimately a new perspective on why
things matter does the day-to-day of
sort of like thinking of superstring
theory for example when you're working
on something like super string theory
does it feel like it's connected
directly to answering those questions or
does it feel like it starts to get
removed and sort of operate in a more
theoretical space well we like to use
the big questions as motivation we
deeply want to know the full story of
creation the full story of how the
universe began we'd love to understand
the deep nature of space and time these
kinds of questions are why many of us
certainly for me it's the case went into
the field in the first place but your
question is a good one because when
you're in the midst of doing the
research
it's like any other subject the detail
their daily grind if you will can often
be fairly disconnected from the big
overarching goals so you know I have
students that come to me and they they
want to work in physics and all they
have in mind are the big huge questions
and when I describe them hate to make
progress toward those questions you got
to do mathematical calculations you've
got to do experiments you got to write
computer programs you got to do
simulations for many of them that's a
bit of a shock but that's the way you
make progress in the day-to-day sense
how would you sort of ballpark the
progress that has been made like over
the last 10 50 and 200 years on
answering some of these questions in
other words there's camps that say we're
never really going to know the origins
because we can't can't really go back in
a way that would give us those answers
there's others who say maybe we will but
like aside from the end point that we
may or may not get to what's the what's
been the progress that has been made
well it's been utterly stunning right if
you if you go to the for this extent of
the timeline that you mentioned go back
200 years to say the early 1800s we were
just beginning to gain an understanding
of some of the most rudimentary forces
at work in the universe how electricity
and magnetism work the early experiments
are just taking place experiments on on
the nature of light these were vital
developments but when you compare them
with what we understand today the
insights that have come from special
relativity Einstein
general relativity again Einstein
quantum mechanics and on through the
developments in unification that have
swept through the 20th century and into
the 21st I mean right now we can do
mathematical calculations that tell us
what the universe was like a fraction of
a second after the beginning and then we
can use those mathematical insights to
make predictions for what those
conditions way back then should yield
for our observations today and many of
those predictions are borne out to
fantastic accuracy by
powerful equipment that we launched into
space that takes the temperature of the
night sky that looks deep into the heart
of black holes so it is stunning how far
we've come in the last 200 years what do
you think has been the effect of that on
sort of the human psyche as we exist in
the world and the reason I asked I mean
it's it we also it's hard to separate
that from technological advance medical
science changing so drastically travel
like it's it's difficult because those
things have also changed so much but
what's your sense of how our
understanding and day-to-day lives are
different based on what we now know that
we didn't 200 years ago well I don't
think you can give a uniform blanket
answer for all human minds there are
some of us who are deeply interested in
these ideas even if we're not doing
research on the topic and have allowed
the insights of modern science to affect
our outlook on the world and given us
the the laudable perspective that there
are true qualities of reality that
research both experimental and
theoretical equipment together with say
mathematical insights can reveal there
are others though who enjoy the fruits
of those undertakings as you mentioned
the technology that has emerged from the
deeper understanding but have not taken
in that mindset and it's really
unfortunate especially in the situations
that we find ourselves in today when
there are some who feel that reality
ultimately is a matter of opinion it's
not a matter of opinion I'm not trying
to downgrade the value of opinions on
certain issues but in terms of true
qualities of reality here on planet
earth and in the wider cosmos there is
such a thing as right and wrong there is
such a thing as fact and fiction there
is such a thing as expertise that can
yield insights that can determine
the correct course of action on vital
issues and not everyone has taken in
this basic quality of scientific
advancement over the past two three
hundred years right well so I mean now
we have the the phrase alternative facts
is an interesting one that that has
surfaced and these ideas of you know if
I don't like your conclusion I can just
kind of reject the premises that you use
to build that up do you think that
that's been more acutely weaponized
recently in society
it certainly has especially when you've
got leaders who have that very
perspective or at least leaders who
leverage that perspective by using it as
a tool or as you describe as a weapon to
advance certain political perspectives
and that is deeply troubling and as
we're beginning to see has the capacity
to yield deep tragedy what's the
solution in your mind to that because
I've read some interesting pieces that
say it's not as simple as we have to
start teaching critical thinking and
philosophy and epistemology earlier that
there's a bigger divide and a bigger
picture issue than simply that I I agree
although I would say that that is part
of the solution I I I can't help the
optimistic side of my personality from
saying I just feel that if we could get
kids at an early stage to really
recognize the power of scientific
insight not abstractly but you know I've
taught kids and I've seen them undergo
that transition from confusion about
something to mastery even if it's a
small element of math or physics and
that move from confusion to clarity can
be life changing
because your way of thinking about the
world and your recognition of your power
to understand the world can radically
change but I agree that's not the full
it's not the full solution because we
find ourselves in an era when many
people and by many I I don't
you know the number that I'm talking
about so don't hold me to sort of
details of numbers here but there is a
segment of the population that makes
decisions not based on thinking through
policy but rather who else is supporting
that policy it's the group think it's
whether or not you want to be in that
group or the other group as opposed to a
rational evaluation of policy and
perspective and that kind of identity
politics needs to needs to shift because
that is not the appropriate useful way
to set policy yeah I'm curious what you
would think about the motivations of oh
so let's just to give an example the tea
party in 2010 right this was a movement
that succeeded to the extent that it did
because of individuals voting for people
who were pushing policies that were not
going to be good for them as individuals
but like Jonathan height for example
argues they were policies that they
identified as good for the group in
which they were members or you know
membership maybe is a bit of a too
formal a term for it isn't that kind of
individual versus group thinking a
factor in what you're describing here
it's huge it's exactly what I'm
describing you know if you were to and
Jonathan probably did because he is a
great social scientist and goes out and
gets the data Simon that they've
collected data if you interview the very
people who are supporting a given policy
and ask them why they are supporting it
some will have thought it through no
doubt but many will not have thought it
through because that's not the way that
the decision is made
rather the decision is made in the
manner that you describe do you want to
be identified as being part of that
group of people who for whatever reason
you feel more of a kinship with or do
you want to break ranks with the group
that you feel that kinship with in order
to follow a policy that is not widely
accept
did by the initial group and
unfortunately that kind of perspective
and that kind of decision-making is
prevalent and it's not the kind of
decision-making that ultimately is good
for the world so to step back from the
zoom out from this a tiny bit I have
this idea that maybe is very naive and
I'm curious what you think about it
which is if we were to make contact with
alien intelligence and find out it's
real if we were to figure out some of
the big answers that people in your
field are looking for about our our
place in the universe
etc I have this idea that issues like
gay marriage and debt and deficit and
stuff like this would evaporate because
everybody would immediately have this
awakening as a result of this new
information that we have is that
incredibly naive would we just kind of
adjust and keep having the same
disagreements we're having well I think
the answer depends a lot on the details
right it's certainly the case that
having a common enemy is a powerful
force of unification fortunately and
unfortunately at the same time when we
can identify a common enemy it allows us
to bind together into an even larger
group if that will aid in our survival
and look many of our predilections
emerged from evolutionary pressures
across you know tens of thousands of
generations and the ability to come
together into socialized groups has been
an important means by which we have
gotten to our place of dominance in the
world so it's not surprising that we
have this sort of inbuilt reaction to
certain kinds of pressure certain kinds
of challenges and once it's challenges
it is a common enemy but you know I like
to think that if we encounter the aliens
maybe it won't be an enemy maybe be a
very friendly relationship and if that
were the case maybe they would reveal
deep truths that somehow the world would
listen to but I have a feeling that it's
and maybe over a long stretch of time
that might be possible but the notion
that I think you are articulating that
all of a sudden we sort of lift
ourselves up from thinking about all of
the issues here and all of this now is
sort of secondary to this larger kind of
conversation we're having having with
the aliens I suspect that would not
happen at least not on the kinds of
instantaneous timescales that you have
in mind well part of what makes me doubt
it would happen at all is that humans
seem to have this incredible ability to
just adjust to what reality becomes and
it becomes the new baseline and things
sort of return to some kind of baseline
in some way ya know it's certainly the
case you know I was on an airplane you
know at JFK on the tarmac on September
11th 2001 and I could I saw the the
plane hit the tower
from my seat in the plane I had a clear
shot right from you know Queens into
Manhattan and so there was a sense at
that moment that that the world would
completely change that nobody would live
their lives the way that they once did
and that was true for a while and there
certainly have been changes that
occurred by virtue of 9/11 without a
doubt but I think many people reverted
at least pretty close to the lives that
they led if they weren't directly part
of the tragedy or if they didn't have a
loved one who is directly part of the
tragedy we do have this you can call it
resilience this ability to sort of
revert back to the way that we once were
and so I I kind of agree with you that
that is the the default development that
we certainly have seen happen over and
over again that we find a way of sort of
acclimating to the new environment and
taking our old lives and fitting it in
to the new jigsaw puzzle as best as we
can and then going forward from there
when it comes to the debate that's now
being had about if and when we go to
Mars and do those Homo sapiens need to
become an interplanetary species to
survive on some very
technical or basic level that will
eventually be true in the sense that at
some point the Sun will engulf the earth
and earth will no longer be a place that
humans can live for the practical
questions that are being asked now about
do we go back to the moon first
and then look at Mars what what is it
that we do next does that timescale even
remotely matter or or is climate change
or something else a factor that much
sooner is going to kind of point us in
one direction or another
well the kinds of timescales that will
make the earth uninhabitable such as as
you describe the Sun swelling and
engulfing the inner planets they may
actually engulf planet Earth and five
billion years those time scales are so
long billions of years as I just
mentioned compared to the timescales of
everyday life that I don't think they
have any real relevance for policy or
planning that we might do at the moment
I don't like to think of traveling off
of planet Earth as the solution to the
climate issues ultimately if we don't
change our ways we'll destroy every
world that we inhabit and that's I don't
think the way we want to go about
populating the wider solar system or
even at some point maybe even the galaxy
we have to change our mindset and become
responsible stewards of whatever planet
is playing host to our civilization and
that requires a radical change in
mindset one that goes away from greed
and focuses upon the good of the whole
and that requires leadership not the
kind of leadership that we have today
but there are leaders that have the
capacity to reach people in a way that
inspires them to change make them want
to be part of the larger collective
because it will make them feel good it
will make them feel like a and
responsible citizen of planet Earth by
virtue of the kinds of things that they
are doing to preserve the plan
and to to abet the planet to make the
planet a better place I think is doing a
good job right now of that well we're in
such an unusual situation right now that
is that it's very hard to to point to a
leader that I would say you know if we
would just have a leader like that but
they certainly are our climate
scientists who have been out there
leading the charge and look I have to
tell you these are vital issues but you
know I can't sit here and say that I'm
in a climate activists that I've been
pushing the envelope of these issues
myself why is that you know we all have
grown up into a world and develop
different kinds of interests and
expertise and and it's very hard to
shift away from that right my footprint
is in mathematics and in physics and in
in communicating those ideas to a wider
audience and those things are important
too so it's trying to find a way that
everyone is so deeply invested in the
cause and can contribute in a way that's
somehow iconic to their particular
ability to contribute and I don't I
don't think we've really found the the
means of bringing out the best of
everyone for these vital overarching
issues so I don't want to only say that
it's got to be sort of an individual
leader but I think leaders can have the
capacity to inspire at every level all
the way down to the individual citizen
and leaders of that sort of think could
make a profound difference last thing I
want to touch on since you mentioned
these these strange times that we find
ourselves in what's your perspective on
what's going on with the corona virus
pandemic yeah I'll leave it wide open
whether you want to talk about curves or
whether you want to talk about
leadership or whatever the case is
where's your mind at this point on the
issue I mean there's so many things to
say but maybe just to stream line it one
thing that I see happening over and over
again and I'll speak to this from the
perspective of a mathematician yeah
scientist is the failure of so many
people to recognize what exponential
growth actually means and and and and
obviously what I mean by that is the the
point of exponential growth is that the
curve of growth starts out so slow that
at first you just don't think there's
any issue at all but then the curve
slams into you with such velocity in
such power that if you react to it
hitting you then it's just too late so
what that really means is the word over
reaction I think has a negative
connotation in everyday usage yes but in
this situation you have to overreact in
the sense that if you are only reacting
to the things that are literally
happening it's too late
you need to react to things that will
happen which means today you need to
overreact in order that you are prepared
for what's happening next and what I see
happening now is we're constantly just
reacting which means we're constantly
chasing after the curve right that seems
that applies to everything from saying
hey Mississippi only has a hundred cases
whoa now there's a thousand - we don't
really need this many ventilators right
now and then all of a sudden we do yeah
and you know - just to bring it down to
sort of a concrete individual level you
know I was on a book tour you know for
for this latest book and I wanted to
cancel various engagements so I'd speak
to the organizers and they'd say there's
no issue very few people and our
community are affected by this come
it'll be fine I'd be like no you don't
get it the point is when things are fine
that's when you need to act strongly so
that it stays fine nobody could get this
idea we've been speaking with Brian
green professor of physics and
mathematics also directs Columbia
University Center for Theoretical
Physics were linking to a number of his
many great books Brian I so appreciate
your time today thank you I enjoyed it